you've actually been tested twice after
I left I sent in a secret diner and they
Sicari filmed everything filmed filmed
do we need a reservation we just have so
much yeah we okay
you can you give me a steer on what to
have I can't really decide what do you
fancy
oh I'm feeling quite hungry hungry yeah
I'm feeling quite hungry things not to
miss if you're sharing would be Pettis
and would be charged and where's this is
this mainly southern India no this is no
weapon North you brat I could try as
well so be similar to Rajasthani oh no
no Rajasthan is a lot more feature dear
whereas ours is a lot of delicate right
okay knowledgeable great first
interaction of the dials the food will
speak for itself you know we have that
as a given so it's up to me to kind of
make that person feel comfortable if
they have questions to answer them
openly and with as much information as
second gear so let's try one of these we
go award-winning cartoonist first
love that coconut remove level up
through our mandate that for real 20 30
seconds going to tasting different
flavors are still coming through just
going to swap a curry quite late in the
day and see what they do
excuse me could I change one of my
curries could I
it's alright any goes any any vegetable
handy of it yeah yo his bags it's good
guy I couldn't have done with that
better you could ask you could say that
this one do we have a bit more punch in
this one you see we keep our arm of that
it's only if you do to make that one a
little bit hotter look hot so yeah how
about doing we're not not to the degree
that you know you just laugh us when we
walk out the door
I loved it and I came back like a fresh
dish no hassle at all it's so refreshing
to see that level of flexibility
there's no intimidation you're not make
him feel awkward there's no guilt if I
if I hadn't have behaved that way in
front of my customers I know two people
in the kitchen would have been very
angry at me please get past this place
and never come home actually
surprisingly it's not somewhat best
Indian food probably ever eaten let's
blow me away it's been really fantastic
fresh sourced expertly done and done
with passion and knowledge
we'll find pretty well done thank you
you made me feel nervous because you
raised the bar so high but I didn't
think you could do that again
I'm feeling fantastic
you know Gordon Ramsay big big man
telling me that you know everything
we're doing is good we were nervous
before I just can't contain it so far
Prasad of punching way above their
weight but I have concerns over how much
this tiny Russian depends on bobbies
front-of-house charm